So first let's look at a little bit more in detail a,
a very well-known form of a camera, a single-lens reflex camera.
This is an example of one.
It has a lens and the whole body.
I'm going to take the lens off.
And it basically now can see more details of this camera.
We'll look at it much more in detail in a few seconds.
But you basically see that there are certain aspects of this camera.
There's a viewfinder.
In there there is a mirror which moves away.
We'll see examples of that a lot.
And of course, this is where the shutter release is.
So this is a standard film camera here.
I wanted to also show you this.
Most of your concern that I've exposed film, this was an exposed film already.
We will be looking at more detail what a film like this looks like.
But this is again, you know, one of the more widely used form factors for
professional photography.
So here I'm showing you now a cut out of the same camera, or similar camera.
Here you can see all of the details that we looked at.
This where the view finder was.
The focus, or zoom ring and the lens.
And I took this out before I showed you any of this stuff, were right here.
The shutter release button is right there.
This is the one that when you press opens the mechanism, so
let the light in to where the film would be.
The lenses are all in the mechanisms right here.
There is a diaphragm.
And we'll talk about the diaphragm and all of that kinds of stuff.
Because that's where all of the openings are controlled between these
lenses to allow the right kinds of light into the camera.
And of course this was a film camera, so there is where the film is.
In the new modern digital cameras of course,
the film has been replaced by a CCD sensor or CMOS sensor.
Again, something we will be looking at in much more detail later.
And all of the focal plane shutters are all mechanisms that are built in here.
That actually let again, different things happen in terms of
how the focal planes and everything as I suggested,
to get the right kinds of light into, to where the film is.
Now, of course, you noticed, and I showed you the thing, there was a glass here.
Basically single-lens reflex,
this thing opens to allow you to get the light in correctly.
And this, the prismatic sensor, that let's the light into the viewfinder so
the viewfinder can see exactly what the lens is seeing.
And as soon as the shutter is released, the mirror moves up and
then the light basically goes and hits the film.
So you actually get to see exactly what you're seeing will the one,
the image that will be registered.
And actually then imaged on the sensor or the film